il s'était fixé pour objectif de se
mettre d'accord dimanche soir au plus
tard
mais après un week end entier de
tractations à huis clos et une dernière
session de négociations dans la nuit
les responsables de la droite allemande
ont échoué ils ne savent donc pas
derrière qu'il se rangeront à l'automne
lors des élections législatives en vue
de succéder à angela merkel qui quittera
la chancellerie après le scrutin de
septembre et 16 années en poste
deux candidats sont en lice d'un côté le
président du parti démocrate-chrétien
armin l'achète et de l'autre le leader
de l'union chrétienne sociale en bavière
marcus odeur si armin laschet talent
avantage de diriger la plus grande des
deux formations politiques et d'être
soutenu par les principaux cadres de son
parti
sa cote de popularité semble faible
selon une enquête de la chaîne ard
44% des allemands juge markus schoder le
plus apte à conduire les conservateurs
aux élections contre seulement 15% pour
son concurrent
les deux hommes qui avait d'abord assuré
vouloir se mettre d'accord entre eux
comme sur leurs candidatures respectives
marcus odeurs paraît d'autant moins
enclins à céder qu'il a obtenu dimanche
à une très large majorité le soutien de
l'organisation des jeunes conservateurs
allemands inquiet des risques de
scission liés à cet affrontement
nous ne laisserons pas un débat
surchauffée au sein des partis mr cd ou
et cs ou apporter la discorde et la
division au sein des jeunes
conservateurs allemands
les deux candidats ont eu suffisamment
de temps pour prendre une décision
cela ne s'est pas produit et nous nous
voyons maintenant obligés de nous
positionner
cela a été fait avec une nette majorité
pour markus soeder si aucun des deux
candidats n'est prêt à renoncer les
députés des deux parties pourrait opter
pour un vote une possibilité à propos de
laquelle le vice président du groupe
parlementaire cdu csu johan va de poules
a émis des réserves
je n'accepterai pas un vote au sein du
groupe parlementaire
si le chef de mon parti armin laschet tu
ne le souhaite pas pointé du doigt pour
avoir entravé l'éclosion d'une relève
naturel au sein de sa propre famille
politique
anguel à merkel refuse de se prononcer
publiquement sur sa succession